[Music]
back in the 1960s Italian architect
Paolo Soleri believed that the urban
planning of his time
was not sustainable he believed the
cities were too big too wasteful into
isolating his dream was to build a
harmonious town that would balance
architecture and ecology he thought this
is how people are meant to live simple
social sustainable are here the locals
are known as arcanas and this side is
our urban laboratory so where he called
his philosophy our ecology and he wanted
to prove that it was more than just a
utopian vision he wanted to make it real
so Larry was once a student of the
legendary American architect Frank Lloyd
Wright and like right he had the
students construct his visionary
buildings by hand what they learned his
philosophy and methodology salera lived
nearby in Paradise Valley Arizona his
home in studio called Kazan T is now
surrounded by golf courses and
McMansions however it remains a
brilliant example of organic
architecture today the subterranean
buildings and winding paths are open to
the public and you can see they seem
ahead every time
at arc Asante most of the structures are
built using a method called silk casting
dirt pulled from the site is used to
create forms which are then filled with
concrete
once the concrete sets the forms were
broken and brushed away with the dirt
returning to the earth walkways bridges
and stairs connect the structures
natural solar energy is used for warmth
in winter while don't sand canopies
cooling summer there are spaces for
living working and entertaining just
feet away from each other since 1970
over 7,000 people have lived and worked
at Arcosanti right now about 80 people
live here from all corners of the globe
since the early days arc Asante has been
funded by the sale of polish Larry's
famous wind bells these bells are cast
by hand in this foundry
[Music]
no new buildings have been dedicated
since 1989
and so Larry passed away in 2013 but
Arcosanti is still a laboratory where
city living
is explored plus the foundation now has
a couple of rooms available on Airbnb
and a music festival called forum
Arcosanti is held here in the spring
this community was intended to be a
prototype so Larry thought that there
will be many ARCA scientists at each new
version would be an improvement one has
to accept the notion of failure he said
the next step will be more promising
than the last
[Music]